Ellen Williams please stand up
these are the sentences that you will
serve on count one there will be a
sentence of six months imprisonment
on counts three to five the sentence
will be three years imprisonment
concurrent on each count but consecutive
to the sentence on count one giving a
total so far of three and a half years
there will be sentences of Five Years on
counts five six and seven concurrent
with one another but consecutive to the
sentences already imposed
finally there will be a sentence of one
year and three months imprisonment on
count eight and six months imprisonment
on count nine those sentences to run
concurrently with each other and the
other sentences imposed that gives a
total sentence of eight and a half years
imprisonment
you will serve half of the total
sentence of imprisonment in custody
after which you will be released on
license
the days spent in custody will count
towards your sentence
you've spent 361 days on a qualifying
curfew because of that the time you must
spend in custody is reduced by 179 days
if that figure is incorrect it can be
corrected later without a further
hearing
on release your license will be subject
to conditions if you breach the terms of
your license you'll be liable to be
recalled to serve the remainder of the
sentence
there is an application for a serious
crime prevention order I find that this
is a serious offense for the purposes of
this application there are reasonable
grounds for believing that the order
will protect the public I exercise my
discretion in favor of making the order
as sought with amendments to the effect
that she may also possess a tablet and
games console and you may also be able
to operate a work and a personal email
that order will run for a period of five
years from the 17th of February 2025
I order deprivation and destruction of
the items on page one of divider eight
of the Crown's bundle of documents
if the statutory surcharge applies the
order can be drawn up in the appropriate
amount